jason statham has been beating up bad
guys for 20 years ever wondered which of
his movements stand out among the rest
was it a fast and furious fight an
impromptu life or death love scene keep
watching to find out
everyone who's seen the fast and the
furious tokyo drift the third entry in
the fast and furious saga knows that the
following movies from the fast and the
furious to fast and furious six are
prequels they all lead up to han's
inevitable retirement and death as seen
in the climactic car chase in tokyo
drift still when the post credit
sequence of fast and furious 6 revisits
han's fatal car crash nobody expects the
revelation that his death was no
accident it was murder what's more the
killer is revealed to be none other than
jason statham's deckard shaw setting the
stage for him to be a major threat in
furious 7. while this retcon of han's
death is itself retconned in f9 which
reveals he faked his death with the help
of mr nobody the impact of statham's
surprise appearance and the hype it
brought to furious 7 cannot be
overstated dominic tiretto and his
family are being hunted by a blood
thirsty assassin and it'll take all
their skills to survive the wrath of
deckard shaw
jason statham may be in a league of his
own when it comes to action super
stardom but he's not the only hunky brit
with impressive high kicks enter scott
adkins star of such films as universal
soldier day of reckoning and triple
threat adkins has earned a reputation as
one of the toughest action stars out
there for very good reason naturally it
was only a matter of time before he and
statham went toe-to-toe in single combat
that opportunity finally arrived in 2012
with the expendables 2. while sylvester
stallone's barney ross fights the main
villain played by jean-claude van damme
statham's character lee christmas fights
van damme's lieutenant hector played by
adkins hector has a knife while statham
is armed with knuckle dusters and the
two square off in a bloody duel while he
takes a few hits along the way christmas
eventually gains the upper hand
ultimately punching hector into the rear
rotor of a helicopter rather than being
turned into a pink mist the impact is
portrayed more realistically the rotor
is destroyed though not before it rips
off hector's head and one of his arms
it's a grisly sight but it only appears
on screen for a fraction of a second
hardcore gore hounds will find
themselves going through it frame by
frame to better admire the r-rated
carnage
computer classic
directed by the dynamic duo of mark
neville dean and brian taylor the crank
movies specialize in sensory overload
and testosterone-fueled audacity they're
effectively parodies of over-the-top
action movies what with their steadily
diminishing sense of reality and open
mockery of the audience as a result
these movies aren't for everyone are you
interested in watching an absurdly
unhinged jason statham kick butt while
surrounded by characters who mix r-rated
caricature with saturday morning
cartoons if so you will enjoy the wild
ride offered by crank and crank high
voltage while crank starts out
realistically enough its stylistic
sensibilities slowly overtake the movie
in ways both subtle and overt as the
movies go on the characters become
increasingly self-aware the finale of
prank high voltage has statham's
character chev chelios stare at the
camera and raised his middle finger
directly at the viewer while on fire and
standing next to a swimming pool no less
like we said it's not for everyone but
the crank movies are worth watching at
least for these moments of sheer
unpredictability
the crank movies are arguably more
remembered for their sex scenes than for
their action sequences this makes sense
the premise of these movies is that
protagonist chev chelios must keep his
heart rate up or else the poison in his
body will kill him one way he keeps his
heart going is by having public trysts
with his girlfriend eve played by amy
smart these scenes present in both
movies would be unwatchable and
disturbing if it weren't for the surreal
tone of these films in the world of
crank public expressions of affection be
they on a horse race track or in the
middle of the street are just part of
the formula as the action sequences are
obscene and ridiculous the romance
scenes need to maintain the same level
of bizarre energy to that end crank is
successful in achieving what it sets out
to accomplish you'll never forget
watching stay them and smart frantically
create friction on a set of stadium
stairs
oh god what are you looking at
when a giant prehistoric shark declares
war on humanity and starts eating
everyone in sight only one man and a
bunch of supporting characters can fight
back that man is jason statham the meg
released in 2018 follows statham as he
does battle with the gigantic shark
while trying to protect his comrades and
innocent beachgoers this wild film has
its fair share of pg-13 terror though
director john turtletop originally
intended for the film to be a
blood-soaked r-rated gore-fest
nevertheless a decent amount of
nastiness remains in the film much of it
due to the fact that the marine life
does a lot of the bleeding rather than
unlucky humans ultimately the megalodon
shark is killed after statham's
character cuts it open with his
underwater vehicle and stabs it in the
eye with a harpoon drawn to the scent of
blood in the water a swarm of smaller
sharks rush to the scene and devour the
meg in a bloody mess thus nature
corrects itself and finally eradicates a
species that should have died out
millions of years ago
one of the first scenes in michael
mann's 2004 masterpiece collateral sees
tom cruise's mysterious character pick
up a briefcase from a balding man in a
dapper suit played by jason statham he
only appears in a single scene but he
dresses exactly like his character in
the transporter frank martin does some
viewers speculate that he may be playing
martin himself making this a subtle
crossover others believe his casting is
an allusion to his famous role but
there's no real intended connection
between collateral and the transporter
either way statham's presence helps set
the tone for collateral which stands as
one of men's finest films its gritty
realism and incredible digital
photography give it a unique look that
has rarely been matched by any other
filmmaker save for man himself meanwhile
tom cruise and jamie foxx offer
fantastic performances that explore
masculinity and duty and culminate in
one heck of a subway showdown
the entire expendables franchise is full
of memorable action sequences many of
which feature jason statham from taking
down bad guys with throwing knives to
beating up a squad of middle-aged
basketball players statham kicks all
kinds of butt in these movies perhaps
his most memorable moment in the 2010
first film comes when he and stallone
take down a bunch of soldiers via an
absurdly enormous explosion after
escaping in their jalopy of a plane they
decide they're not going to leave
without causing a bonafide spectacle
stallone turns the plane around while
statham goes through a secret
compartment and emerges out of a hole on
the plane's nose after stallone dumps
fuel all over the pier from which they
escaped statham uses a flare gun to
ignite it this engulfs the dock in a
massive fireball killing a great many
soldiers in the process
directed by paul w s anderson death race
a loose remake of the 1975 cult classic
death race 2000 stars jason statham as a
prison inmate forced to compete in the
eponymous death race it's a no holds
barred vehicular combat challenge that
plays out like an r-rated take on mario
kart or crash team racing complete with
on-track power-ups that unlock the
vehicle's weapons while statham takes
part in his fair share of hand-to-hand
fights the real draw here is the twisted
metal style mayhem which anderson always
a reliable action director delivers in
spades death race has no shortage of
grisly kills and outrageous car wrecks
by far the film's standout moment comes
when statham and allied driver machine
gun joe played by tyreese gibson are
forced to take on the dreadnought it's a
massive vehicle armed with heavy machine
guns flamethrowers and impenetrable
armor they knock it off the board by
tricking it into colliding with an
immovable obstacle at terminal speed
causing it to flip and over end and
throw its passengers into the air the
amazing crash is captured in full and
delivers exactly what viewers want from
a movie called death race
there are debates to be had as to what
movie contains the best jason statham
fight scene however there is no debate
as to which movie contains the most
sensual jason statham fight scene that
honor belongs to the transporter in
which a shirtless frank martin kicks
over multiple tubs of grease covers his
shirtless body with the slippery goo and
proceeds to engage in a shirtless battle
with half a dozen bad guys did we
mention he's shirtless thanks to veteran
action director corey yuen this fight
has wonderful kinetic energy much humor
and bone-crunching excitement comes from
the henchman's attempts to grab statham
who is too slippery to hold it's a truly
unique action scene full of visual
invention and delightful stunts that
give the viewer an appreciation of the
human body's ability to perform
incredible feats also we cannot
emphasize this enough he's shirtless and
covered in grease you don't see that in
many action thrillers
hatchet harry is a man you pay if you
owe those words are spoken by jason
statham in 1998's lock stock and two
smoking barrels when the protagonists
consider the possibility of not paying
the money they owe hatchet harry sathum
relays the story of smithy robinson who
failed to pay his debt or offer a
reasonable explanation as to why he
couldn't as a result hatchett harry
reached for whatever was on his desk and
bludgeoned pours smithy to death with it
that object just so happened to be in a
modestly sized sex toy the sight of
harry going berserk on smithy is as
absurd as it is intimidating and the
idea of him doing something similar to
the protagonists is enough to inform
their motivations for the rest of the
movie statham's narration of this
infamous episode filled with seeming
admiration at harry's audacity elevates
the scene to a whole other level it's
hilarious memorable and let 1998
audiences know that jason statham was
going to do great things
there's no shortage of fight scenes in
the crank films from bloody shootouts to
brutal fisticuffs and even a mid-air
brawl in the skies above los angeles but
the best part of these movies is their
unpredictability the viewer honestly has
no clue what's going to happen next at
any given point nowhere is that more
evident than in the downright absurd
godzilla fight in crank high voltage
chev chalios has fought hundreds of bad
guys by the time he faces off against
johnny vang in an electrical power
station as such the movie doesn't
indulge in a traditional fight instead
the scene suddenly shifts taking on the
aesthetic of a grainy japanese kaiju
movie chelios is inexplicably portrayed
as a giant chev zilla with vang
transformed into an equally gigantic
monstrosity the two proceed to engage in
a fight that pays homage to any given
godzilla versus movie complete with
absurd wire stunts and sets that look
like they're made of cardboard it makes
no sense and it's one of the best
sequences in the whole movie don't even
think about it
from the moment jason statham's
character is introduced audiences know
it will all come down to a one-on-one
hand-to-hand grudge match between
deckard shaw and dominic tiretto when
the time comes in furious 7 their
inevitable confrontation does not
disappoint while the fisticuffs are
firmly in the realm of pg-13 action the
hits are nevertheless brutal these
characters pummel each other with the
full force of their desires for
vengeance deckard for his injured
brother owen and toretto for his fallen
friend han the fight is pretty close
throughout and beautifully choreographed
for maximum impact gravity-defying
suplexes and absurd flying elbows
somehow feel visceral and believable
here even though no human could ever
survive the hits these two titans of
testosterone endure the battle
culminates with vin diesel's
unforgettable line think about street
fights
the street
always wins
[Music]
like most of furious 7 that line barely
makes sense but it's so sincere that you
can't help but love it
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos but
your favorite stars are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]
you